hi i'm sabrina carpenter and this is the
wired auto complete interview
[Music]
why do i keep seeing sean kingston in my
head oh my gosh i'm so sorry microphone
[Music]
who's sabrina carpenter
who is sabrina carpenter
me
well there's actually probably someone
else in the world named scooter
commenter so i'm just one of a couple i
think there's only a few i've checked
that actually who did sabrina carpenter
play in harry potter great question
i was wrong so it was a great experience
and i like grew up on that set and my
daniel so it's cool because they're just
great people yeah i'm a huge huge
potterhead i went to actually was
performing close to universal in uh
florida and went to harry potter world
for the day and i went into the room
where they like choose your wand for you
like it's a very like big moment that
one was chosen for me and then i brought
it home and now i cast spells on
everybody it's great who did sabrina
carpenter
voice in phineas and ferb it's
interesting because i ended up working
with the creators stan and swampy of
phineas and ferb on my next animated
series milo murphy's law but i was just
like a small like guest role i like went
in for the day and it was kind of like
one of my first voiceover jobs where
they just had me do like a bunch of like
random voices so i literally don't even
remember who i would have even played
but there's like throughout a few
different episodes like me just as like
random guest things that they would be
like a little girl like screaming or
crying or random stuff that they use all
the time so i have no idea if you find
it let me know voice impressions um what
was it this morning literally i was
going oh it makes me want a hot dog real
bad and i'm just working on my jennifer
cool and trying to figure it out she
actually played my mom in like a short
series that i worked on and she was so
wonderful i'm still working on it who
i am sabrina carpenter
lyrics am i just like not remembering my
childhood at all yeah i guess that was a
song that i like cover in the talent
show that was like one of my first guest
appearances on a show which was really
interesting to perform
i will be completely honest i don't
remember the lyrics
i'm not gonna toss it in your face i'm
gonna go this way
what's sabrina carpenter what is sabrina
carpenter allergic to
i've been dying to talk about this
because all my friends forget every time
i'm like i'm allergic to apples and
almonds apples and almonds they're like
okay cool cool cool so i like see them
the next day and they're like serena i
got you these almonds if you want like
or like i just made almond butter
they're always forgetting my allergies
but i can have like baked apples really
random but like raw apples i'm allergic
to and then yeah anything with almonds
which is unfortunate
i'm also slightly allergic to dogs and
my cats as well and um
peaches oh i forgot the main one metal
it's a really random one like nickel
like i'm allergic to metal so like any
time like i wear like fake jewelry
really expensive taste um it's
jewelry like i break out my ears bleed
essentially and then if i wear like
jeans like it's a whole thing so it's
the struggle's real what time was serena
gardner born you and me both want to
know my mom tells me
this every couple years and i always
forget i think it's 8 52 in the morning
but then some years it's 11 52 because i
don't remember but it was in the morning
i believe what does sabrina carpenter
say in french
which means my heart is yours forever
and that's like a lyric in one of my
songs paris i wrote this bridge in
french i guess i just want to learn how
to say that because i always tell people
that my heart is theirs forever i give
it away so easily
what kind of dog does sabrina carpenter
have he's a little bit of a mutt his
name's goodwin he's a celebrity he's a
maltese lostop so longhair chihuahua and
a yorkie so just really special unique
and he's an angel like truly an angel
and
i love him so much i got goodwin on my
13th birthday so at this point i've had
him almost 10 years which is crazy i
grew up having cats we were a cat family
and they were all strays because i lived
in the woods we had woody bow ginger and
mocha and then they all grew up and then
someone that's terrible i love them and
i miss them but i you know i've had time
to grief i then moved uh to california
and now i have two new kittens benny and
bjorn i don't know if anyone's an abba
fan yeah so they're precious and they're
little british short hairs they're white
they're beautiful how sabrina carpenter
how tall not how tall was sabrina
carpenter and girl meets
coins what gummy's i think i was
probably 4
10 or 4 11 for a solid the whole show i
remember when i hit five foot i was like
doing the macy's thanksgiving day parade
and i like found out that day i measured
myself and i was like did it happen and
then i don't think i've grown since
how long is sabrina carpenter on
broadway oh
sore subject we'll put in a sound
effects of like the crowd going ah
i made my broadway debut in mean girls
on broadway which was such a gift and
such a special moment in my life but it
was unfortunately two days before the
cute little global pandemic so i got to
do two shows so i was on broadway a
whole two nights
i'm
hopeful that i'll be able to go back at
some point even if it's not mean girls
then back to broadway eventually because
i loved it at the best time how many
octaves
can sabrina carpenter
sing it's such a funny question i've
worked with my vocal coach eric vitro
since i was like 12. he's told me that i
have four to five i'm always really
really like adamant about taking care of
my voice and he's the best and i love
him so much shout out to eric
how is
google how is sabrina carpenter related
to joey king how are we related we're
not i wish we were joey's one of my best
friends but yeah not by blood we're not
related although it's funny i'll never
forget one night we went to this
restaurant in georgia and like
literally three people that night
stopped us to ask us if we were twins i
kid you not we look nothing alike and
and and they were just convinced they're
like oh my gosh you guys are the most
beautiful twins you've ever seen are
like
what my mom and her mom were also there
with us and so they was like
what it was so funny what a bizarre
night and no one's ever said that since
how is sabrina harbinger related to
nancy cartwright it's my dad's sister
she's the voice of bart simpson i don't
know if you ever heard of him and then
like also 89 other characters on the
simpsons and a bunch of other shows like
rufus and kim possible and chucky and
the rear rats like everything literally
so
legend we work on like kind of different
ends of the industry but i've learned so
much just from like observing her and
she's so talented why sabrina carpenter
why sabrina carpenter ukulele it's
almost a sentence and almost a question
but like we're just missing a few why
sabrina carpenter play ukulele why buy
sabrina carpenter on ukulele because i
have a song called why the ukulele i
wish i knew them that's why you're
looking them up yeah i actually haven't
i haven't played y on the ukulele but i
have to look up the courts myself so i
can help you why sabrina carpenter
genius you tell me i ask myself every
day no i'm kidding did someone actually
look that up
are you sure they were born
it was a wednesday why did serena
carpenter start her oh i thought that
was the end
photography account so you're talking
about my sister
we do look very similar to be fair
because we're related but my sister has
an iconic photography account called
don't shake the polaroid because she's
an iconic photographer that's really
funny that you think it's my photography
account because we look alike i guess
and she posts a lot of photos of me to
be fair we love taking photos together
it's like our favorite thing in the
world i'm very very lucky to always just
be like creating beautiful imagery with
my sister on her photography smash that
follow button not there but like
wherever it is
does sabrina carpenter have any special
talents no no i'm kidding
i pretty much share everything uh that i
have to offer i don't think i have any
special talents other than like the
eyebrow thing like i couldn't do that
but you can't see because i have bangs
now but underneath the bangs they're
dark enough i like do like the
caterpillar wave
eyebrows does serena carpenter play an
instrument i do i play a bit of
piano guitar bass
ukulele and drums when i'm feeling
rhythmic
the sabine carpenter have siblings i do
i'm the baby of my family i have three
older sisters and i have a puppy going
and two cats does serena carpenter dye
her eyebrows
so
that's crazy someone look that up
because they were like they're too dark
i don't buy it
unfortunately they're natural yeah this
was the way you know man upstairs was
like hey this looks good yeah i i don't
know what to tell you i'm confused as
well but i was born a blonde with dark
eyebrows is
sabrina carpenter related to the
carpenters if i say yes will you believe
me i've always like wanted to say yes to
this question because i don't know like
where the musical thing comes from in my
family my parents are not
singers or songwriters my mom's a dancer
but um no not related to carpenters but
big fan sabrina carpenter playing
spider-gwen oh my gosh that's so funny i
don't know i feel like anytime a marvel
is brought up by the way i get this
immediate panic even though even if i'm
not working with them just like the
sheer thought of maybe working with them
that i'm like i can't give away anything
is serena carpenter gemini
no and i feel like a quicker search
would have been what serena governor's
birth sign or zodiac sign i'm a tourist
actually is sabrina carpenter a dancer
yeah
i started dancing when i was two because
my my mom put on me and all my sisters
and dance lessons which was so fun and
then i i really was dancing for quite a
long period of time until
i was maybe like 14 or 15 and then i
kind of stopped for a while but i got to
dance again in my my netflix movie
working which was really fun that was
like the first time i danced in a long
time so i was like sore is serena
carpenter
going on tour
yes
eventually the dates aren't out but
definitely touring's a huge part of my
life and i'm always kind of gonna love
it when it happens and when it's safe i
can't wait to see everybody like so
excited to play the next album on tour
what sabrina carpenter what's sabrina
carpenter's first song the first song
that i released kind of officially i
guess was can't blame a girl for trying
real big throwback megan trainer
actually wrote that song which is kind
of how i met her let's talk about
ukulele that song is fully ukulele so
sweet very different person who sang
that song versus now it's so funny
because like some friends of mine like
they just always love that song they're
like that song's still bang so hard what
is sabrina carpenter's new song about
skinny dipping glad you asked it's kind
of a multitude of things it truly is
kind of this like inner monologue inner
dialogue with yourself but also kind of
coming to terms with
your past and your present and kind of
being able to like
sit with the discomfort of things that
have happened in life and not hold a
grudge or hold any resentment but just
be able to like skinny dip in water into
the bridge be free what was sabrina
carpenter in sofia the first great show
iconic i played princess vivian one of
sophia's friends classmates and i had
this cute pet dragon i know kind of a
subtle flex i think i first auditioned
for that show when i was like 11. i was
so young also my character if you look
her up she has the craziest bangs like
you thought we had bangs like she has
bangs she was on some other wave too
they're like the short ones i don't know
she's she's cool what movies does
sabrina carpenter play in
on
netflix alice um for netflix work it and
tall girl for netflix we're just getting
started love my netflix family it's all
been really really fun sabrina carpenter
thumbs lyrics
big mouthful somewhere in the world
there's a father and a mother and a
father son of the brother the mother and
the daughter of the mother the mother
and then they wanted to multiply
that's literally the first verse it's
the family tree i don't know i'm
probably not going to sing them all for
you right now but
take a moment look him up sabrina
carpenter curt and bangs
whoa
that's crazy
thank you
for searching here they are in case you
were like looking for them this is kind
of how they move they get annoying at
times i have to trim them pretty often
thanks for being a fan
serena carpenter yellow dress work it i
actually love that it's so interesting
to know like the the
like character wardrobe that people like
really gravitate towards and that dress
was a like a custom dress so i could be
able to like dance a little bit easier
in it but we modeled it off of another
dress that was like a red dress in that
same shape but i love the color yellow
so i was like can we please make it
yellow can sabrina carpenter
do gymnastics big question mark i cannot
do a flip however i can do the splits
and i could do a round off and i could
do a one-handed cartwheel when i'm sober
so
can sabrina carpenter cook also big
question mark i can watch people cook
really well and give them support i'm
like a big like you're doing great type
of person i wish i could comfort meal
i'd have so much comfort in my life can
sabrina carpenter speak japanese you
know
not a lot but um what is it
i think means i'm hungry because i
remember a fan said that to me once and
then i said it on stage because i
thought it meant something else and then
they all started laughing and i was like
what like what did i just say like did i
say something bad and i was like no and
then like someone was like you said
you're hungry and i was like fair enough
i was like honestly i am so it worked
out can sabrina carpenter draw i do love
to draw i don't i don't know how great i
am but i do love to draw in my free time
my grandma was an artist so drawing is
one of my favorite like therapeutic
calming activities and serena carpenter
sang for us
well not every song i've ever thought of
is just gone
why do i keep singing sean kingston in
my head oh my gosh i'm so sorry
microphone
i'm thinking of the most random songs in
my head right now amy winehouse
meets you downstairs in the bar and
hurts you know i'm no good by amy
winehouse with two lyrics uh misplaced
so still as i'm yourself
someone wants to know if i dyed my
eyebrows
that's shocking i guess because they're
homegrown locally
yeah that's so interesting and nothing
about my feet so great day
thanks so much wired you guys are the
best i hope you enjoyed